honnêtement ça serait plus ça ne me
choquerait touche de saint louis à qui a
choqué non plus que vu les audiences
est ce que rapporte le programme va bien
je suis si fier j'étais faire des
recherches
les 30 secondes de pub autour de scènes
de ménage ses 53 mille euros non c'est
la station qui avec plusieurs secondes
tu es plusieurs minutes finalement c'est
un truc de très rentables aux valeureux
zaoui ah ouais nan franchement me remets
me ramener à la vraie vie moi je vais
être choqué parce qu'en un mois et demi
elle a fait un an de salaire d'un arrêt
france est donc ramené à la vraie vie je
fais de chauffe je vais être choqués
mais si je reprends ce que dit maxime je
suis choquée qu'elle ne soit pas assez
payés finalement puisqu'elle est là
depuis dix ans c'est des personnages
clés raymond et huguette c'est les
personnages clés de la série m6 se font
beaucoup d'argent avait avec league est
donc je me dis ramener à ce qu'elle
représente dans la série ça paraît pas
beaucoup avancé mais l'office qui paye 1
c'est la production ça paribas sa part à
beaucoup paraissent que les autres sont
plus que c'est peut-être parce qu'elle
elle salue convient aléas gl10 moi ça me
suffit pour vivre mais ça me paraît pas
beaucoup et c'est ramener à la vraie vie
évidemment c'est beau c'est énorme et
c'est multi rediffusé il a raison oui
j'ai omis oui enfin y'a pas des foules
de textes parfois il dit deux mots mais
je les adore aller d'aller très bien il
est rivé salve bah oui ça là des salles
des charges et de bovins trois seuls
cinq des six mots mais voilà en revanche
moi je peux comprendre sa chapelle ce
que j'ai dit c'est très bien pour elle
oui d'accord mais je te signale c'est
comme nous ça fait partie du système des
intermittents et qu'on ne travaille pas
c'est les français qui payent quand même
son salaire oui vous ça vous choque pas
vous votre salaire alors mais bien sûr
que si ça me choque c'est ce que je
pense que vous êtes tout ont payé que
marion game on fait bien sûr ouais mais
ça vous choque
mais moi je travaille aussi je suis
première trouvé mais on savait que vous
avez dit amel a toujours dessiné honnête
parce qu'il a toujours dit je m'affale
mais j'ai dit on se retrouve et que ses
revenus à la française c'est vrai ça oui
et non bien sûr durant un mois et demi à
l'après suranné tu vois c'est sûr mais
la vraie question c'est est ce qu'on
peut comparer ce milieu là la vraie vie
tu essaies scènes de ménages
à chaque fois j'ai eu des débats ici en
disant ce n'est pas la vraie vie c'est
une vie de luxe et une vire de
privilégier et femmes en ce moment là
avec ce qui m'est sont les
intermittences et une vie plus riche on
parle pas des d'intermittent
on parle de nous là nous on parle de nos
l'indien déjà qu'ils sont chez eux au
chômage nous on est prêts on travaille
quand même et ils ont quand même les
contrats y travaille quand même
évidemment l'événementiel l'intermittent
l'hôtellerie les bistrots cinq
catastrophes on est donnée d'un chien
mais on a quand même prévenu et moi
j'adore franchise de janvier moi aussi
j'adore la franchise de gens me et ça va
nous servir pour la décrocher